j'ouvre notre second débat consacré à un
thème qui passe souvent sous les radars
médiatiques celui des blessures
psychiques des militaires elles sont
pourtant presque aussi nombreuses que
les blessures physiques leur
invisibilité rend la prise en charge
plus compliquée avant de voir ce que
l'armée a déjà mis en place qui pourrait
être amélioré un témoignage celui de
Fernand Balzar c'est un ancien des
forces spéciales dans la marine victime
d'un attentat terroriste au Mali c'était
en 2015 sujet signé Mathias as
il est des blessures qui ne se voient
pas pris dans une embuscade lors d'une
opération spéciale de l'armée française
au Mali en 2015 Fernand Balzar frôle la
mort on est sous la pluie de
bombardements
plus explosion de véhicules
kamikaze et lorsque je vois ce véhicule
arriver qui explose je suis projeté et
quand je rouvre les yeux
je crois que je suis mort c'est
paradoxal je crois que je suis mort bon
j'ouvre les yeux
bon ça siffle de partout dans ma tête je
sais plus j'ose même plus regarder mes
jambes parce que je suis persuadé que
j'ai plus rien
parce que j'arrivais plus à mettre
debout enfin c'est tout est on sait plus
en fait l'onde de choc est terrible mais
le soldat est miraculeusement mis à
l'abri par un collègue quelques semaines
plus tard il rejoint sa famille mais
ressort rapidement des souffrances
physiques d'abord troubles digestifs
perte de sommeil et de mémoire
déséquilibre avant de s'enfoncer dans la
douleur psychique je m'isolais je
restais dans le noir complet j'étais
plus là pour ma femme mes enfants
j'étais plus là j'étais absent mon corps
était là mais plus mon esprit j'étais
ailleurs je voyais pas au début
cette blessure par ricochet qu'elle est
impacter ma femme et mes enfants non on
s'en rend pas compte on sait pas
un traumatisme qui déchire la famille de
Fernand l'homme envisage un temps de
quitter femme et enfant pour devenir
sans domicile fixe mais l'ancien de la
Marine nationale peut compter sur ses
proches sur ses amis et accepte de
franchir la porte du médical donc si on
garde l'humain la Fondation la base de
la construction de la reconstruction
sera saine et solide et on pourra monter
les étages
un par un en toute sérénité toute
confiance et ça durera dans le temps
bien sûr c'est possible
une reconstruction qui passe par le
partage aujourd'hui il aide à son tour
des frères d'armes qui comme lui ont
connu la désérance on perd la confiance
en soi et on perd surtout la confiance
envers les autres donc un blessé coûtera
un blessé donc et imbécile c'est ce qui
se passe dans la tête dans notre blessé
si c'est l'impact de la blessure sur la
famille donc on se comprend
sans se parler sans juger si aujourd'hui
Fernand va mieux c'est aussi parce qu'il
a retrouvé un travail à la capitainerie
du port de Calais alors mon bureau à
l'heure actuelle est en haut de la tour
là de la pyramide voilà pour avoir le la
meilleure vue possible afin de pouvoir
anticiper
tout ce qui est trafic maritime et
sécurité nautique un rendez-vous
quotidien avec les navires qui entrez
sortent un poste à responsabilité
surtout qui rend sa dignité à celui qui
un jour fut premier maître dans la
marine
c'est inévitable hélas mais c'est pas la
priorité la priorité c'est de retrouver
cette dynamique ça apporte une sérénité
[Musique]
une sérénité vous retrouvez en fait vous
vous retrouvez on se retrouve avec
soi-même Fernand rejette le terme de
syndrome post-traumatique auquel il
préfère blesser psychique car la
blessure à l'image d'une cicatrice peut
nourrir l'espoir d'une guérison
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités le colonel Bertrand lahudde
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes psychiatre
médecin-chef professeur agrégé du Val de
Grâce titulaire de la chair de
psychiatrie de psychologie clinique
appliquée aux armées et chef du service
de psychiatrie de l'Hôpital
d'Instruction des Armées déjà Jean-Marie
Bockel bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous
êtes président de l'association
Solidarité défense ancien secrétaire
d'État la défense ancien sénateur
évidemment du Haut-Rhin et votre
association vient d'organiser un
colloque justement c'était à la fin du
mois de mars sur l'accompagnement des
blessures psychiques des militaires
Hélène Romano bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi vous êtes psychologues clinicienne
psychothérapeute spécialiste du
traumatisme chez l'enfant et vous
publiez les enfants et la guerre aux
éditions Odile Jacob et Mélisa balski
évidemment est resté à mes côtés
éditorialistes pour sciences publiques
je vous propose quelques chiffres pour
commencer le chiffre des blessures
physiques on regarde la décennie 2010
3400 soldats français qui ont subi des
blessures physique la source et l'armée
de terre et si l'on regarde les
blessures psychiques toujours sur cette
même période on a ce chiffre de 2800
soldats français Bertrand l'autilité
peut-être difficile à évaluer ce chiffre
est-ce qu'il est sous-évalué sachant que
peut-être qu'il y a des des soldats qui
n'osent pas en parler ou qui tarde à en
parler oui en effet l'interprétation des
chiffres et généralement assez
nécessitent une interprétation plus
technique et on peut difficilement
prendre la valeur absolue en tant que
tel mais on voit comme des chiffres
assez importants et d'ailleurs assez
comparable entre les blessures physiques
et psychistes qui nous amènent à
considérer les blessés dans leur
ensemble un distinctement d'une certaine
manière de cette caractérisation et
d'ailleurs on sait très bien que les
blessures physiques sont souvent en tout
cas fréquemment accompagnés également
d'une blessure au sens d'une effraction
de la parie psychique également est-ce
qu'il y a autant de moyens pour les
blessures physiques
psychique pour les blessures physiques
tout à fait les dispositions sont les
mêmes les acteurs sont pas tout à fait
les mêmes ils sont en changeant mais
pour terminer sur la remarque que vous
faisiez qui est très importante c'est
qu'effectivement on a aussi une
difficulté d'évaluation au sens où les
symptômes qui sont liés par exemple
conséquences d'une infraction
traumatique et on entend dans les
témoignages de caractère très sensibles
que ça peut avoir peuvent parce qu'ils
vont générer d'un vécu de honte de
culpabilité un besoin d'isolement ou
même des symptômes qui empêchent tout
contact social retardé voir différé de
façon très importante la rencontre avec
les soins et empêcher parfois la demande
d'aide qui va se faire d'une manière
plus latérale soit initiative de
l'entourage ou à l'occasion d'autres
symptômes qui ont nécessité donc il y a
un véritable travail de repérage mais on
a une appréciation assez globale de
l'importance de ces phénomènes
Jean-Marie bauquel des militaires qui
n'osent pas en parler de ces de ces
blessures psychiques ça ça arrive
souvent et d'ailleurs je rajoute à la
question le parce que je m'y attendais
pas ce séminaire qui dit syndrome
traumatique j'aime pas trop le terme
lequel vous employez vous nous notre
coloc du 30 mars nous l'avons intitulé
accompagné la blessure psychique du
soldat car ce terme est extrêmement
clair et c'est vrai que
nous avons eu de très nombreux
témoignages et vous étiez d'ailleurs
présent également
à cette rencontre ou de nombreux soldats
d'un Amiral qui fut au gradé jusqu'à des
soldats officiers sous-officiers de
terrain
se sont exprimés et ont commencé par
dire d'ailleurs la manière dont à un
moment donné
souvent pas tout de suite souvent à leur
retour parce que tout de suite il y a
plein d'occupations le chef il s'occupe
de ses soldats il exerce ses
responsabilités mais comment souvent
à leur retour ou même parfois plus tard
il découvre peu à peu et ils comprennent
peu à peu qu'ils sont
concernés et qu'ils vivent cette
blessure parfois d'ailleurs leur famille
s'en rend compte avant eux et nous
l'association Solidarité défense lorsque
nous sommes engagés pas seulement ce
colloque mais à travers nos bénévoles
qui sont aux côtés de ces blessés nous
n'entendons jamais nous substituer
évidemment aux professionnels au
psychiatre au personnel médical et c'est
pourquoi nous parlons bien
d'accompagnement d'accompagnement des
blessés d'accompagnement des familles à
côté de l'institution pas à la place 2 à
côté nous sommes amis d'institutions
mais c'est blessé peut-être plus encore
que les que c'est physique parfois
d'ailleurs certains blessés on les deux
et bien ils ont besoin à la fois d'être
soutenus par l'institution c'est
spécialistes et aussi les moyens
évidemment pour pour les aider mais ils
ont aussi besoin
d'avoir des interlocuteurs qui soient
hors de l'institution alors c'est même
j'allais dire psychologiquement
important pour eux certains ont même
peur parfois plus besoin d'être hors de
l'institution on y reviendra peut-être
mais je voudrais on parlera évidemment
de l'effet sur la sur la famille mais
sur le le
j'allais dire retard de diagnostic c'est
certainement pas le bon moment le fait
de retarder de de ne pas en parler tout
de suite soit parce que effectivement on
est pris dans une sorte de tourbillon
soit parce qu'on a honte est-ce que ça
complique le travail ensuite dans la
prise en charge pour vous répondre
peut-être rappelé que les fractions
psychiques s'il y a la confrontation à
la mort et quand vous êtes confronté à
la mort vous êtes confrontés quelque
chose on n'a pas les mots c'est
indicible donc j'ai apporte soi-même on
n'a pas les mots il y a la honte la
culpabilité mais juste on n'arrive pas à
mettre les mots pour ce qu'on ressent
donc déjà ça il y a un retard au
diagnostic quand on est militaire et
pour débriefer intervenir auprès de
nombreuses victimes professionnelles
c'est très différent les militaires
parce qu'il y a aussi la notion de
protéger la notion de mission d'État
donc allez dire que on se sent pas bien
à les dire que c'est difficile quand on
arrive à le dire c'est extrêmement
compliqué peut-être plus que pour
d'autres professionnels un enseignant un
infirmier on voit bien aussi dans ce
domaine là à quel point c'est compliqué
donc ça va retarder plus la question de
des troubles qui certaines fausses
manifeste en différé mais je voudrais
aussi insister sur la dimension qui a
été rappelée dans le témoignage de honte
de très fortes culpabilité d'avoir
failli de pas être en capacité d'avoir
peur de perdre son poste de pouvoir
partir en mission etc et le dans la
remarque qui était faite de parler de
blessures psychiques qui n'ont pas de
troubles c'est aussi parce que souvent
les gens qui ont été confrontés à la
mort dans l'expression qu'ils ont ce qui
ressenti ils ont l'impression de devenir
fou et sa psychiatrise beaucoup trop
traumatique est un des stress
post-traumatique c'est un terme
psychiatrique donc je suis blessée
psychiquement c'est peut-être plus
facile à accepter même si au niveau
clinique on sait qu'il y a un certain
type de signes mais pour la personne qui
le vit voilà je suis blessée
psychiquement c'est moins psychiatrisant
et une telle peur quand on les voit en
consultation ils ont peur d'être fous et
quand ça décompense quand tout d'un coup
il y a les cauchemars les revêtissances
il y a la famille qui dit je te
reconnais pas il y a les troupes
d'addiction enfin tout ce qu'on connaît
il y a un moment de déstabilisation et
cette peur de la psychiatrisation est
très forte colonel a eu la prise en
charge elle commence quand est-ce que
est-ce que ça ça démarre avant vous
anticiper ce qui peut se passer
est-ce qu'il y a forcément un médecin
psychiatre sur sur un théâtre
d'opération comment ça se passe en fait
un peu tout ça effectivement les choses
ne se limitent pas une intervention
médicale au sens une consultation
il y a tout un travail qui va d'ailleurs
concerner d'autres acteurs que des
soignants au sens de ce qui se joue en
amont déjà des déploiements d'émissions
des déploiements opérationnels donc il y
a tout le cadre de la préparation
préparation opérationnelle et qui en
passe aussi par une évaluation médicale
de ce qui pourrait éventuellement être
déjà présent ou susceptible de
s'aggraver ou se compliquer pendant la
mission le déroulement de la mission
bénéficieux si d'un accompagnement
soignant donc avec des équipes médicales
de proximité qui sont des médecins des
forces au plus proche forcément des
psychiatres forcément eux qui passent
psychiatre mais les psychiatres partent
en mission également mais en tout cas il
y a des des médecins généralistes donc
militaires qui sont tout à fait
compétents et formés je dirais
l'intervention médico-psychologique au
plus près donc des combattants et le
psychiatre qui lui est présent sur
l'ensemble du détachement et qui va se
déplacer en fonction des besoins ou
éventuellement mettre en oeuvre si
nécessaire des moyens de rapatriement ou
des interventions thérapeutiques que ce
soit sur place au métropole pour la
suite donc ça c'est le temps de la
mission et comme ça déjà été évoqué même
si les troubles psychotramatiques ne
sont qu'une des facettes une des
fractions au somme toute de des troubles
psychiques en situation opérationnelle
mais en tout cas c'est celle qui est
notre sujet aujourd'hui
ces troubles sont fréquemment
d'expression différé c'est assez un
médecin par nos interrompre qui va venir
au contact de du soldat lui dire il se
passe proposer ses services et le soldat
va peut-être pas forcément il se passe
un événement exceptionnel une attaque
une explosion de requête et donc tout le
monde est impacté avec un vécu assez
adéquat c'est une chambre de situation
donc on sent ce stressant et choqué qui
ne permet pas du tout de présumer la
suite et donc on peut avoir
effectivement des complications
immédiates qui vont nécessiter des soins
médicaux ou médico-psychologiques et
certains patients qui vont présenter des
symptômes évocateurs tout de suite qui
sont repérés
identifiés donc traiter sur place mais
ça n'est pas la majorité des cas et il
n'est pas rare que dans ce genre de
situation il y ait un effet de
récupération qui est lié à la
préparation qui est très efficace qui va
permettre de contenir des choses au
fonctionnement aussi du groupe qui est
un groupe structurel ou groupe militaire
ça n'est pas une foule les organisée si
le jeu de très particulier qui
fonctionne et qui protège et ou d'autres
facteurs que je n'ai pas lister et qui
va permettre de terminer la mission et
voir parfois donc au retour de la
mission pour reprendre le film de mon
explication il y a aussi un suivi par
les acteurs de commandement fonction des
événements qui ont été vécus qui sont
listés donc ils sont révélus un peu à
distance également médical donc qui se
superposent avec le suivi régulier en
place pour les militaires et il arrive
parfois que ce soit bien plus
tardivement voir l'occasion d'une autre
mission les événements les années plus
tard ça peut être des années plus tard
Emilie
c'est ce que vous disiez c'est à dire
que je sais pas si c'est quelque chose
d'anthropologique mais en tout cas en
France on a du mal avec la mort on a du
mal avec le deuil on fait plus de deuil
il faut que ça passe très rapidement la
résilience elle doit être immédiate on
doit pas trop s'attarder donc encore
plus pour des militaires c'est honteux
en effet d'être si fragile qu'on
pourrait être encore faible devant les
événements qu'on a vécu donc ça c'est
une difficulté pour les obligations de
performance même dans cette période je
pense qu'on a vraiment dépassé le cas
avant on faisait quand même un an de
deuil on mettait il y avait du noir il y
avait quand même des rituels qui
faisaient que on passait ce temps-là et
on dit d'ailleurs que le deuil respecte
un cycle avec un certain temps donc on
est plus du tout là-dedans très
difficile pour les militaires d'accepter
ça d'accepter à l'encontre d'aller à
l'encontre de ça et de l'autre côté la
médecine la médecine française aussi
elle est plutôt là pour donner des
réponses avoir des résultats
immédiatement sur une blessure physique
c'est un peu plus facile sur une
blessure psychologique comme vous l'avez
dit ça peut être réussi sur le moment ça
peut être complètement raté ou en tout
cas à continuer des années après ça peut
être même un retour de mission et
quelque chose qui n'aura pas été digéré
psychologiquement qui va revenir et
c'est vrai que la médecine a du mal
souvent c'est plutôt des médicaments la
sismothérapie c'est des choses comme ça
qu'on essaie de pratiquer pour se dire
on a trouvé la solution mais ça peut
durer en effet des années alors je vous
propose on va essayer pendant ce déb
d'écouter régulièrement des témoignages
évidemment de militaires français voici
un militaire qui s'appelle Julien
Lacombe il a été diagnostiqué en tout
cas il a exprimé son trouble psychique
en 2013 c'est important la date parce
que il décrit aussi la réaction de ces
frères d'armes regardez écoutez le droit
leblesse est difficilement pris en
compte il y a un besoin opérationnel
d'avoir des personnes forts moralement
physiquement et à partir du moment où
vous dites ben non je ne suis plus de
personnes fortes moralement physiquement
d'un coup d'un seul vous êtes mis au
banc de votre de votre section de votre
unité de votre régiment ou mes mes
frères d'armes il y a quelques mois
nakunasol ne me connaissait plus d'une
certaine manière donc
c'est un côté très très violent
effectivement à gérer cette espèce cette
espèce de déclassement même au jour
d'aujourd'hui j'ai encore du mal à me
définir comme blesser parce
qu'effectivement j'ai la chance voilà le
problème de la blessure psychologique
c'est que la blessure de se voit pas
elle se vit au quotidien elle se ressent
au quotidien dans des dans des moments
de faiblesse des phases de haut des
phases de bas voilà Julian Julien
Lacombe qui est salarié de skybird View
qui est une entreprise je le dis parce
que qu'elle a été créée par un ancien
militaire lui-même victime d'un syndrome
de stress post-traumatique et qui
embauche des soldats qui est qui
souffrent de de blessures psychiques ou
de blessures physiques voilà c'est
important aussi de mettre en avant cette
cet engagement de ce chef d'entreprise
mes frères d'armes ne me connaissaient
plus alors c'est 2013 j'imagine que ça a
évolué depuis Jean-Marie Bocquel ou
est-ce que ça peut encore être une
réaction quand on ouvre dans les
témoignages qui reviennent espèce de ça
peut être aussi notre rapport à la à la
à la maladie ou à la mort parfois en a
une réaction de gêne ou de recul et
d'ailleurs à ce propos
on a eu lors du coloc auquel on faisait
allusion une séquence très intéressante
qui a été celle des chefs qui s'exprime
comme chef réagissant face à ces
situations au sein de leur corps de leur
régiment etc et parmi les chefs il y
avait un intervenant du matin qui était
intervenu en tant que blessé
blessé
post-traumatique et
donc qui est resté chef
de Oran d'ailleurs c'est un amiral qui a
eu des responsabilités très importantes
après encore et qui témoignait
d'ailleurs le matin de l'acte de
reconnaître de se soigner et de se
tourner vers le professionnel vers le
psychiatre en l'occurrence militaire et
lui disait mon retour d'expérience comme
disent des militaires c'est que chaque
fois que sous les ordres il y avait des
soldats qui revenaient de mission et
bien je leur demandais une seule chose
c'était parfois l'occasion vous savez de
cette petite séquence de de
ça ce qui se passait
dans différents endroits dans des hôtels
où les soldats pour un peu décompression
de décompression et il leur disait je
vous demande de consulter un psychiatre
militaire même deux minutes
mais allez-y allez-y faites
donc je vous dites l'importance de
l'encadrement pour éviter la mise au
point même si vous allez bien ayez ce
contact peut-être ça durera deux minutes
mais peut-être ça vous aidera plutôt et
sans attendre aussi longtemps que
certains d'entre nous dont moi-même
disait-il et j'ai pu attendre voulant
d'abord régler le problème par moi-même
avec ma famille etc puis à un moment
donné ce qui m'a sauvé c'est quand j'ai
consulté le psychiatre quand j'ai
franchi ce pas et là je vous demande de
le faire de toute façon
systématiquement
c'est important les Américains je crois
je crois qu'ils parlent ils parlent du
syndrome de Rambo on peut imaginer un
peu ce que c'est de quoi de quoi il
s'agit en fait prendre avec ces
termes-là mais c'est dans les métiers
alors les militaires le SAMU par exemple
les métiers où il y a cette notion
d'être infaillible et de protéger la
nation c'est l'univers ils sont ils ont
aussi cette mission là et la très grande
difficulté d'oser dire bah là je souffre
c'est c'est compliqué parce qu'il y a
une peur d'être mise au rebut moi je
vais bosser travailler dans un SAMU
pendant très longtemps et les collègues
qui n'allaient pas bien n'osaient pas
aller voir la médecine du personnel par
craint d'être changé de service on a ça
chez des pompiers militaires on a ça
dans un certain nombre de métiers parce
que il y a cette idéalisation si du
métier par la société cette volonté
performance faut être infaillible et on
oublie qu'on est des faiblesse le droit
à la faiblesse direct difficilement
prise en compte nous sommes des
États-Unis et ça fait partie un
traumatisme la résilience utilisée à
toutes les sauces pour ne plus rien dire
mais ça veut pas dire qu'on va oublier
c'est une blessure elle est là on
apprend à vivre avec on peut en faire
une force mais elle ne s'efface pas et
ça c'est un vrai travail pour le coup à
faire avec des autorités ce que ça prend
du temps et ça nécessite certaines fois
des prises en charge longues pour le
militaire mais sa famille et ses enfants
alors je vous propose un autre
témoignage
issu d'un documentaire qui avait été
diffusé sur sur notre antenne sur Public
Sénat le souffle du canon on est au cœur
d'un stage du centre de ressources des
blessés de l'armée de terre dans le parc
du Mercantour c'est une structure qui
accueille des femmes des hommes qui
souffrent de blessures psychiques
souvent retour d'Afghanistan autour du
Mali alors dans ce documentaire les noms
des témoins n'apparaissent pas je vous
propose d'entendre cette femme militaire
qui soignait les blessés dans un camp en
Afghanistan voilà ce qu'elle nous dit
j'avais un attachement à l'armée qui
était sans conteste voilà si j'aurais
fallu donner ma vie j'aurais donné ma
vie aujourd'hui c'est malheureusement
plus le cas parce que j'y arrive plus et
j'ai le sentiment que voilà je devrais
peut-être pas dire ça mais j'ai le
sentiment d'être un peu lâché par
l'armée par l'institution qui devait
trouver un poste adapté et qui
finalement me trouve rien quoi et je
suis obligé de partir en civil et
ça je reviendrai partir de l'armée dans
cette
comme ça en fait j'avais jamais envisagé
ça quoi
voilà documentaire signé Nicolas
mangaçon on le remercie d'ailleurs de
nous permettre de réutiliser ces images
je regroupe les deux témoignages
docteur Bertrand la hutte pour pour
savoir comment l'armée évolue dans la
prise en charge parce que là il y a deux
blessés qui disent bon bah voilà on a
été j'étais un peu mis au banc ou alors
l'armée a pas trouvé une solution de
finalement pour que je continue de
travailler et d'être
utile à ce corps comment comment vous
répondez il y a plusieurs choses qui
font entendre et ce sont deux
témoignages qui sont évidemment
différents mais qui se complètent et qui
nous montrent à la fois les effets du
groupe parce que c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est probablement poussé à son
à son paroxysme dans le groupe militaire
aussi un fonctionnement psychologique
dans le groupe et ce que le premier
enfin l'avant dernier témoignage nous
montrer c'est qu'effectivement quelqu'un
qui va mal n'arrive plus aussi à occuper
cette place dans un groupe un groupe ça
a une fonction ça un certain nombre de
fonctions d'effets au niveau
psychologique qui permettent aussi de
soutenir de protéger contre l'angoisse
c'est structuré ça répondait extrêmement
précises et quand on quand on va mal
quand on souffre un individu qui fait
mal dans un groupe va générer aussi des
réactions qui voient un peu des
réactions en chaîne donc ça vient à la
fois de lui et des autres quoi c'est
absolument ça qu'il faut voir c'est à la
fois il y a 7 dimensions là qui et on
voit bien à quel point c'est difficile
d'aborder les choses sans que ce soit
jugé comme trop
honteux peut-être par l'intéresser ou
alors trop reporté ou projeté sur les
autres mais en tout cas c'est une amie
qui est collective et le groupe bon tel
que ce qui était suggérés enfin ceux
qu'on devine un peu certains ont des
exigences beaucoup plus fortes que
d'autres effectivement ça a été évoqué
l'idéal du groupe d'être Sauveur d'être
combattant d'élite etc rend les choses
parfois plus difficiles et à côté de ça
et le dernier témoignage je vous donne
une bonne illustration et aussi quelque
chose qui est vraiment consubstantiel de
la blessure psychique c'est qu'il y a un
avant et un après et que l'après
comporte quelque chose d'irréparable
quelque chose qui est foncièrement perdu
alors ça ne veut pas dire qu'il y a pas
de matière des soins à autre chose mais
véritablement il y a une perte un dol de
quelque chose qui va rester comme ça
du côté du laisser tomber il y a c'est
aussi la trace la cicatrice quelque part
de la scienceique qu'on entend alors ça
rejoint tout d'un ensemble d'autres
difficultés qui sont celles auxquelles
on va faire les blessés psychiques qui
effectivement ont un parcours
professionnel qui peut connaître une
infection brutale je parle pour les cas
graves et qui doivent rentrer dans un
processus d'abord de soins et ensuite et
c'est la réponse à votre question un
processus d'accompagnement vers une
réorientation professionnelle avec tout
un travail de réhabilitation et de
réinsertion souvent dans un autre métier
que celui dont ils sont ici donc c'est
et attention de choses avec des acteurs
donc une partie médicale un volet
médical et aussi des acteurs non
médicaux depuis le commandement les
anciens combattants tout tout
l'écosystème des blessés c'est-à-dire
c'est l'ensemble de l'acteur médicaux
soignant et non-soignants on va dire qui
contribue justement cet accompagnement
dans les parcours de soins les parcours
de soins dans la durée parfois vie
entière alors justement la partie parler
plutôt du parcours administratif avec
qui qui va nous rejoindre sur ce plateau
rebonsoir audress sans sans mauvais jeu
de mots on peut parler pour ce parcours
administratif d'un parcours du
combattant oui parce que pour obtenir
une pension militaire d'invalidité il
faut de très nombreuses expertises une
qui établit le diagnostic médical une
autre qui permet d'évaluer le préjudice
et puis une contre-expertise réalisée
par l'administration en application du
principe de contradictoires il faut
refaire tout cela pour l'indemnisation
complémentaire dites Bruno tout refaire
aussi si l'état de santé du militaire
évolue c'est ce qu'on apprend dans un
rapport d'information réalisée par le
député LFI Bastien la chose c'était en
2021 alors d'après le plan d'action du
ministère des armées ça pourrait avoir
une vertu thérapeutique parce qu'on met
des mots sur le mal mais certains
témoignages racontent une succession de
contre expertise qui leur fait perdre
pied chaque nouveau papier remet le
blessé face à un échec et puis il y a le
sentiment de devoir se justifier
justifier que l'on est blessé je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure d'une contre
expertise de l'administration elle est
vécue pour beaucoup comment soupçon
résultat certains vont même jusqu'à
développer une phobie administrative je
vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet le
témoignage d'une femme de combattant
blessée elle fait désormais partie des
associations et l'intervenait en 2021
sur le plateau Public Sénat et on a un
des blessés ça fait 3 ans qu'il a pas
ouvert son courrier donc par exemple
j'ai passé une journée avec lui pour
régler ses problèmes de CAF d'impôts
d'être en contact avec l'armée parce
qu'il n'avait voilà c'est des choses il
a besoin pour nous ça nous paraît pas
grand chose mais pour lui rien d'ouvrir
son courrier et de rendre de téléphoner
c'est insurmontable et là on se retrouve
avec des blessés qui sont sur le bord
sur le bas-côté de la route ça on n'a
pas le droit enfin
on doit s'occuper d'eux
et les choses pourraient peut-être
changer Thomas le ministre des Armées
Sébastien Lecornu participait au
colloque que vous avez organisé sur les
blessures psychiques et à la issue de ce
colloque pardon il a tweeté je souhaite
qu'un combat administratif ne s'ajoute
pas au combat contre la blessure
désormais la blessure sera présumée pour
les militaires la charge de la preuve
reviendra à l'administration à faire à
suivre merci beaucoup Jean-Marie bocal
effectivement ce colloque il s'est
conclu avec une sorte de feuille de
route de des propositions que vous avez
pu faire au ministre le Cornus c'est ce
dossier là la partie administrative ça
en fait partie oui bien sûr et le
témoignage de Madame Chauvel et vraiment
à la fois émouvant mais aussi
intéressant parce que elle pointe un
certain nombre de
nécessaires améliorations mais elle
montre aussi j'allais dire en même temps
l'utilité qu'il y ait à côté de
l'administration militaire une prise en
charge extérieure à l'armée aux côtés de
ces personnes et c'est cet ensemble qui
permettra d'avancer on peut pas tout
attendre de l'institution je veux dire
également et je le dis docteur sur votre
contrôle que l'armée a mis en place
progressivement maintenant depuis
deux ans trois ans des maisons Atos qui
sont donc des lieux
d'accueil de ces personnes qui peuvent y
aller volontairement par petits groupes
avec tout un environnement avec une
déconnexion également pendant plusieurs
jours de leur environnement habituel et
avec aussi des liens avec des gens qui
ne sont pas de l'institution donc c'est
vraiment
psychique uniquement ou blesser physique
et psychique les deux physiques et
psychiques
il y a une volonté croissante et le chef
d'état-major
Thierry burqa avait ouvert le colloque
était conclu par Monsieur Lecornu et a
insisté là aussi sur son engagement que
l'institution
face encore
davantage qu'elle ne fait et nous nous
rend compte à nous rendre compte à
Solidarité défense puisque nous avons un
nombre important de bénévoles en région
parisienne et en province qui sont aux
côtés des blessés hors hôpital
je dirais tout au long de de l'année que
il y a à la fois de nécessaire
d'améliorations de la charge de la
preuve c'est une très bonne idée mais
même le jour où la réponse sera parfaite
ou presque parfaite il y aura toujours
besoin et particulièrement pour les
blessés psychiques
d'un accompagnement de et de leur
famille qui ne soient pas que de
l'institution parce qu'il y a aussi on
aurait pu en parler les cabates et
autres services sociaux etc donc l'armée
est quand même bien outillée mais voilà
elle ne répondra même si elle a des
efforts à faire qu'elle fait des efforts
elle ne pourra jamais répondre seul à
toutes les attentes légitimes de ces
personnes c'est la nation qui doit en
quelque sorte et les associations en
font partie se sentir concerné et
d'ailleurs le monde économique des
entreprises
tout à l'heure et ça c'est très
important aussi pour se reconstruire
alors je vais vous donner
malheureusement vous devez partir un peu
avant la fin de notre débat et je
voudrais vraiment qu'on parle des
familles parce que vous prenez en charge
notamment des enfants des enfants de
militaires peut-être peut-être aussi
qu'est-ce qui rend leur cas particulier
d'une certaine façon alors s'il fallait
faire un comparatif pour des des parents
blessés psychiquement parce que les
expertises vont là aussi l'ONEM quand
vous avez un problème médicamenteux les
Expertis c'est un parcours du combattant
pour tout blesser psychique somatique
les expertises contre c'est très
compliqué mais par rapport à un enfant
de militaire ce qui va aussi changer
c'est que le militaire du fait du secret
d'état d'émission bien souvent ne peut
pas expliquer à son enfant précisément
là où il était ce qui s'est précisément
passé il y a une notion de secret qui
est tout à fait compréhensible par
rapport au secret défense et moi je vois
bien la différence entre des blessés
militaires des enfants de blessés
militaires ou endeuillés et des enfants
qui sont des parents blessés
psychiquement dans d'autres
circonstances de travail le fait de dire
les choses d'expliciter de pas mettre à
l'enfant de se représenter ce que son
parent avec eux ou c'était comment
c'était il en a besoin pour mettre en
sens sortir du traumatisme arriver à
l'apprivoiser parce que ça s'évas pas
encore une fois c'est arrivé à le mettre
en sens pour faire un récit ça faut le
rendre disciple faut pouvoir le rendre
intelligible le décrypter et quand on ne
peut pas parce qu'il y a un secret
d'état et ça se comprend totalement
plus compliqué pour les enfants et en
particulier dans les cas d'enfants
douillet de militaires sur la question
et pourquoi et comment il y a des choses
qui ne peuvent pas être dites pour des
raisons de secrets qui se comprennent de
secret de mission et ça pour les enfants
ça peut être compliqué ça peut être
aussi compliqué dans le lien avec le
parent blessé on a vu des femmes et il y
a des papas il y a des mamans militaires
et l'enfant de pouvoir expliquer ce qui
s'est passé parce que l'enfant il a
besoin d'être rassuré sécurisé le parent
ils peuvent blessé psychiquement mais
c'est important que l'enfant comprenne
pourquoi comment et si on lui dit ses
secrets alors qu'au quotidien on lui dit
mais il y a pas de secret si t'embêtais
à l'école faut le dire faut pas qu'il y
ait de secret ça fait quelque chose de
l'ordre de l'injonction paradoxale
difficile très difficile c'est des
accompagnements particuliers est-ce
qu'il faut même si on peut jamais se
préparer totalement à un drame et à une
blessure grave ou à la mort d'un parent
mais est-ce qu'il faut les trouver un
moyen de de qui comprennent que leur
papa ou leur maman on fait un métier à
risque pour qu'ils aient intégré
peut-être
très fréquemment dans les prises en
charge moi je parle des pompiers
militaires des militaires qui partent en
mission des gens qui partent sur des
missions comme ça extrêmement
préservées au niveau des modalités
d'exercice de leur métier les enfants
ont peu leur expliquer avant voilà papa
maman fait un travail particulier il y a
des choses qui se disent des choses qui
ne se disent pas un parent médecin il va
pas donner les détails par contre si
haute il y a le secret médical donc
c'est expliquer à l'enfant mais il
faudrait le faire en amont c'est souvent
fait c'est pas toujours fait on essaye
de le faire c'est perfectible mais ça
complexifie la prise en charge de ses
enfants là et pour conclure vous libère
dans une minute
enfin quand il y a une blessure
psychologique d'un parent il y a
forcément enfin c'est une la palissade
ce que je veux dire mais il y a
forcément des répercussions dans la
famille quoi ça c'est quasiment
systématique je serais très prudente le
côté automatique voilà faut pas
systématiser chacun est différent il y a
la singularité de chacun il y a les
liens qui avaient avec le parent qui
peut être blessé qui sont différents
d'une famille à l'autre mais c'est une
dimension qui est à prendre en ligne de
compte en faisant très attention aux
bébés de militaire moi j'ai pris en
charge des femmes enceintes qu'on
perdent leur mari militaire c'est très
particulier les bébés les enfants tout
petits les 0,3 ans on en parle jamais
qu'on perdit leur père au combat qui
deviennent pupilles c'est un statut
particulier
qui a une signification particulière ou
quand on a les tout-petits souvent on va
pas les prendre en charge les grands les
ados un peu plus mais tout petit on va
considérer ils sont petits ils vont
passer à autre chose ça sert à rien
d'explicité le militaire qui rentre qui
se met à ne plus avoir le comportement
qu'il avait d'habitude avoir des flashs
des des réactions totalement inadaptées
par rapport parce qu'il avait
habituellement plus on est petit plus on
a besoin d'explication donc il faut
vraiment ça être très attentif à cette
question là merci beaucoup
sur notre plateau je vais justement vous
partirez le titre de votre livre les
enfants et la guerre qui est publié aux
éditions Odile Jacob je vous propose et
puis ensuite je vous donne la parole et
Émilie pour parler effectivement de ce
qui est prévu par par le gouvernement
mais je voulais dire on va essayer de
d'avoir le plus souvent possible des
témoignages dans ce débat un autre
témoignage qui est également
issu du documentaire le souffle du canon
nous avons deux anciens soldats qui
discutent et qui reviennent sur une
mission au Mali écoutez
mon pote il a crevé là dans mes bras là
j'étais rempli de sang là pendant 10
jours déjà le temps de finir la mission
tu vois ils m'ont pas changé de tri
j'avais j'avais du sang partout tu vois
et ça ça pue tu vois et après ça m'est
arrivé de la nuque quand je me réveille
de faire des cauchemars je sentais du
comme si j'étais
remplie de sang quoi l'odeur me quittait
plus quoi pendant six mois un an ça me
le faisait ça t'arrivait pas genre de
devoir allumer la lumière pour vérifier
que c'était bien chez toi
je faisais des je sais mes parents je
faisais des rondes la nuit en machette
nous on sait que je faisais des ronds de
la nuit en machette Bertrand là il
commence à se passe juste après un un
tel traumatisme c'est à dire que
elle est normalement il disait tout à
l'heure la peur d'être fou
est-ce que voilà c'est c'est une peur
spécifique aux militaire qui ont vécu de
tels de tel moment ou pas d'ailleurs je
pense qu'il y a quelque chose pour tous
qui est insupportable dans le fait
psychique et d'ailleurs la terminale la
désignation fou qui est plutôt péjoratif
qu'on projette sur l'autre généralement
envoie à la crainte qui puisse se passer
quelque chose pour nous dans ce qui est
somme toute le plus singuil plus intime
de notre expérience et il y a
radicalement quelque chose de différent
entre ce qui serait logé dans le corps
et ce qui touche à notre être notre
identité et un potentiellement donc
effectivement c'est ces expériences
psychotramatiques sont des expériences
de changement radicaux il y a quelque
chose qui qui peut être extrêmement
désorganisé ou pas du tout il est quand
même pas rare d'ailleurs c'est la
majorité des cas où ce sont des
situations qui trouvent à se refermer
assez rapidement et assez spontanément
quel qu'en soit le devenir évolutif et
dans certains cas ça ouvre les portes
une sorte de chaos très symptomatique
avec des symptômes que je n'ai pas listé
qui sont marqués par compétition de ce
qui a été vécu quelque chose qui est
toujours présent qui n'est plus à sa
place par exemple très sensoriel les
honneurs des images qui se surimpriment
avec la réalité ou qui font revivre
réexpérimenter le plus horrible de ce
qui a été vécu dans la nuit dans les
cauchemars par exemple donc ce sont des
profonds bouleversements et qui peuvent
coexister avec une sorte d'effort de
fermeture au niveau psychique pour faire
tenir les choses éviter un maximum tous
les stimuli qui sont susceptibles de
réactiver ce genre de choses donc
ce sont des expériences de grandes
désorganisations psychiques qui cette
prise en charge émie des militaires
blessés on l'a compris là depuis le
début de ce débat c'est vraiment un long
chemin oui c'est difficile c'est long
c'est ce qu'on disait parce qu'on a
l'impression que tout va bien et puis en
fait c'est juste en surface en France la
prise en compte de ce type de blessure
psychique a été progressive on a vu que
des psychiatres militaires qui ont
apporté des soins aux soldats revenus
d'Indochine et puis d'Algérie ont
apporté leur pierre en fait à l'é un
décret publié au début des années 90 en
1990 il permet de reconnaître ses
pathologies comme blessures psychique
ouvrant droit à la réparation donc
c'était un une première étape d'autres
médecins engagés sur le terrain durant
la guerre du Golfe cette fois-ci ont
permis grâce à leur expérience
d'améliorer la clinique des troubles
psychiques de guerre et de mettre en
œuvre toute une doctrine adaptée le
conflit en Afghanistan on en parlait
tout à l'heure ça a été aussi un
déclencheur dans ce domaine avec une
attention particulière pour ses soldats
qui revenaient des combats pour leur
famille aussi et puis aussi pour avec la
mise en place en 2010 d'un temps de
décompression alors si on revient
aujourd'hui comment ce sujet est pris en
charge au sein du gouvernement alors
c'est un des combats de Sébastien
Lecornu dont on parlait tout à l'heure
le ministre des armées qui passe du
temps auprès de ses soldats blessés il
travaille depuis l'été 2022 à un plan
blessé au programme notamment une
amélioration de la prise en charge de ce
syndrome post-traumatique avec une
systématisation prévue du rendez-vous
que vous médical lors des retours
d'opérations donc un premier pas
important pour déceler c'est ce qu'on
disait c'est souvent difficile
simplement d'avoir ce diagnostic là une
meilleure formation des psychologues
assez troubles et aussi prévu une
amélioration des procédures on en
parlait tout à l'heure moins
d'intermédiaire moins de bureaucratie et
puis ça t'inversion de la charge enfin
de la preuve à faire on a parlé aussi
des maisons Atos donc qui était mise en
place depuis 2021 avec un objectif d'une
dizaine dans ce plan pour 150 places à
chaque fois et puis il y a un sujet
important que porte le ministre des
Armées c'est aussi tout ce qui est
décoration médailles en fait une espèce
de reconnaissance améliorée ou en tout
cas facilité des sacrifices que font ces
soldats avec des remises donc de
décoration adaptées alors je le disais
en début de débat on estime en tout cas
c'était les chiffres de la décennie 2010
2800 soldats français qui ont subi des
blessures psychiques à comparer avec les
la prise en charge
150 personnes avec en plus soin pour les
blessures psychiques et physiques là on
est sur une décennie on peut se dire que
voilà c'est encore un petit peu limité
par rapport à ces 2800 blessés
psychiques qu'on compte actuellement et
tout ce qu'on ne compte pas aussi donc
c'est des chiffres qui sonnent un petit
peu il me semble comme un écho aux
difficultés plus générale que que vit la
psychiatrie dans notre pays depuis
plusieurs années en plusieurs dizaines
d'années en tout cas plusieurs années
pourtant les problèmes psychologiques se
multiplient au sein de la population
notamment les jeunes on a vu ça après la
crise covid on a aussi tout ce qui est
acte terroriste qui ont laissé des
blessures psychiques alors on espère que
les soldats comme les jeunes et les
citoyens plus plus généralement puissent
être traités à l'avenir comme il se doit
effectivement de la formation elle est
elle est importante Jean-Marie bocal
avec solitaire et défend je crois que
vous financez des des stages de
reconstruction pour les psychiques en
fait
il y a ce que l'armée fait très bien et
vous en êtes le témoin mon colonel et il
y a aussi ce que l'armée et la première
elle reconnaître aujourd'hui ne s'est
pas fait ou pas bien faire et par
exemple là on a vu le reportage sur ce
stage il faut en tirer les enseignements
beaucoup de ces personnes ont continué à
vivre de graves difficultés après de
toute façon que ces choses là ces
problèmes se règle jamais du jour au
lendemain mais par exemple nous nous
travaillons avec un certain nombre
d'associations souvent petites
associations je cite par exemple à
Augusta qui organise des stages de voile
pour des petits groupes de blessés et de
blesser psychiques et ça fonctionne très
bien en plus les personnes qui les
organisent sont très au fait
sont en lien permanent avec le monde
médical en général et le mot militaire
et le monde
et bien sûr les professionnels de la
psychiatrie militaire en particulier et
c'est un exemple parmi d'autres de
comment dirais d'externalisation
de la prise en charge sur la base du
volontariat de ces personnes en lien
avec leur famille il y a aussi
d'ailleurs parfois des initiatives qui
associent les familles parce que nous
croyons beaucoup à cette dimension
d'accompagnement
il n'y a pas de solution il y a aucune
solution miracle mais c'est en croisant
ses efforts que
d'après les témoignages que nous avons
de ces personnes
on contribue ces associations
contribuent à ce qu'elle retrouve peu à
peu confiance en elle à la fois au sein
de leur famille mais également dans leur
vie professionnelle et dans leur vie
tout court merci beaucoup Georgiens ce
que vous nous disiez tout à l'heure
c'est une mission de la société tout en
tiers merci de nous avoir alerté sur ce
colloque puisque c'est grâce à vous
qu'on a décidé d'organiser ce débat dans
le sens public merci d'avoir d'y avoir
participé je vous donne rendez-vous
demain pour une nouvelle émission et
puis notez votre prochain rendez-vous
politique sur notre antenne ce sera
évidemment dans la matinale Oriane
mansini reçoit le vice-président du
rassemblement national Sébastien Chenu
député du Nord bonne soirée à toutes et
à tous